it's not just k-12 education that
demands the trump administration's
attention
higher education has become a bastion of
speech codes
conservative intimidation and much worse
take the university of southern maine
please take them they're now asking
community members to sign
a black lives matter statement and
anti-racism pledge
what's worse the school will also
publish the names of people
who sign it which in this political
climate means that those who
don't sign it will almost certainly face
retaliation
and maybe even have mobs showing up at
their homes
joining me now john eastman claremont
institute senior fellow and
constitutional scholar
john this is a public university people
pay
taxes and that's what funds this place
they're basically threatening the staff
into signing a political document
document i wonder is that even legal
now it's it's not legal it's not
constitutional and it's it's been that
way for
decades and decades supreme court long
time ago
in a case dealing with jehovah's
witnesses saying the pledge of
allegiance
uh it's a it's a very famous line in
supreme court jurisprudence if there is
any fixed star in our constitutional
constellation
it is that no official high or petty can
be can prescribe what shall be orthodox
and politics
nationalism religion or other matters of
opinion or force citizens to confess by
word or act their faith they're in
i mean this is this is a standard
standard of first amendment law you
can't compel people
to take a particular position when
you're a public university or the
government more broadly
so john somebody doesn't sign this uh
do they sue the university and uh how
long does that
take to wrap through the courts well
that's going to take a long time but
i'd be i'd be concerned if if they're
fired if they're if their
terms of employment are affected thereby
and look i mean we have to understand
the propaganda nature of this the same
thing happened
uh some years ago with the safe space
movement where
faculty that were fully supportive of
the homosexual rights agenda
would put safe space stickers on their
doors the implication of course is if
you didn't
go along with that agenda and put that
sticker up you were an unsafe space
the same thing is being sought here if
you don't sign this anti-racist pledge
which is itself racist i mean it's
it's you know the the author of the
language of this thing has admitted
he wants reverse racism if you don't
sign it then by definition you're the
opposite of anti-racist which must be
racist
it's pure propaganda it has no place uh
in
an institute a governmental institution
a public university
but at some point we got to quit calling
them higher education that's becoming a
contradiction in terms
you know the president appoints judges
and regardless of who the president is
do you think americans are finally
beginning to understand just how
critical it is
that we have a president that appoints
judges who actually have read and
believes in the constitution well i i
think that's right and
we should be really clear here people
are not cheering because this president
appointed conservatives or liberals
to advance an unconstitutional
conservative agenda instead of an
unconstitutional liberal
agenda what they're cheering is that
this president has appointed people who
are faithful to the language of the
constitution
as originally understood and know the
limits of their authority from the bench
john thank you very much for joining us
john eastman great to have you here
thank you